hablamos de esa final de champions
cuáles fueron las virtudes del real
madrid y qué fue lo que condenó al
liverpool ayer en esa final vimos algo
muy claro lo primero es imponerse por
dominio el liverpool intentó hacerse
cargo del partido pero se repitió y no
encontró la manera de hacer daño en
cambio real madrid se impuso por
jerarquía que esa capacidad de tomar
decisiones claras y efectivas a la hora
de imponerse en el juego eso por un lado
y luego creo que el dolo táctico también
lo gana carlo ancelotti se destaca mucho
la figura de courtois el portero del
real madrid donde evidentemente fue
decisivo en unas pelotas pero creo que
fue todo el trabajo defensivo del real
madrid- el que le imposibilitó al
liverpool imponerse de la manera que
sabe hacerlo y estamos hablando de los
laterales bajos unos doblajes en marca
como por ejemplo lo que le pasó a luis
díaz que intenta hacer daño por esta
banda y no encontró la manera no
encontró el espacio y además ancelotti
tenía claro que lo que tenía que hacer
era si liverpol iba a tener la pelota
tenía que incomodar a los delanteros
para que ellos no pudieran rematar
digamos
ya que ellos siempre logran hacerlo y
luego encontramos un equipo que se
sostiene desde el mediocampo con modric
con cross con casemiro ese tridente que
se entiende muy bien en ese medio del
campo y luego la figura de federico
valverde federico al verde que empieza a
hacer un cuarto adelante cuando se
defienden pero también que fue el centro
del ataque del real madrid todas las
opciones se generaron por esa banda
derecha y luego se define con este gol
de inicios por el lado más débil es
decir la jugada empieza por derecha se
termina por izquierda y no se generó
tanto con vinicios entonces creo que
hablamos de un complemento muy buen
partido de carlo ancelotti planteado
inteligentemente porque además real real
madrid ya había demostrado en esta
champions que sabía esperar que sabía
contener y luego hacer daño no sólo en
las transiciones sino con las elecciones
precisas en los momentos justos del
partido ahora vas de jerarquía pero lo
cierto es que en las fases eliminatorias
en madrid no era favorito en muchos
partidos desde octavos como se explica
que el madrid incluso es ayer que no era
favorito saque adelante sus partidos y
gane yo creo que esta es la conclusión o
sea este no es un partido es la
conclusión de un proceso que evidente
ancelotti que agarra el equipo en una
crisis o en una crisis de identidad en
una crisis de resultados y lo que hace
es justamente darle ese poder a
jugadores de experiencia para que sus
decisiones en el campo sean
fundamentales a la hora de tener estos
resultados entonces evidentemente
hablamos también de un equipo que ha
ganado 14 veces la copa de europa esto
implica que a la hora de salir a
disputar con equipos más jóvenes
evidentemente tiende a imponerse de esa
manera y luego de haber eliminado a
chelsea a city
y al paris saint german con esas
remontadas evidentemente venía con ese
pico anímico que es muy importante
emocionalmente cuando se disputan estas
finales creo que lo del real madrid es
la conjunción de los imponderables del
fútbol todo eso que no se puede
controlar más un equipo que yo creo que
fue trabajado inteligentemente por carlo
ancelotti desde la gestión de un
vestuario que evidentemente tiene un
talento que no haya sido reconocido o
que estaba en una crisis insisto de
identidad y luego logró complementar
esas dos cosas lo futbolístico con lo
anímico y en esa conjunción incluso
derrota en uno de los mejores equipos
evidentemente de la temporada porque
hombre por hombre es un equipo
potentísimo y además un equipo de autor
que lo hemos mencionado aquí muchas
veces que solía ahogar a sus rivales por
esa capacidad ofensiva y sobre todo de
hacer daño en esta oportunidad gana
carlo ancelotti con su experiencia lo
vimos para nada es el liverpool que
sofocaba a sus rivales vamos a dejar de
un lado de la champions league para
hablar de la finalísima que tenemos este
miércoles entre y está la campeona de
europa y argentina campeona de la copa
américa que podemos esperar de este
torneo nuevo que enfrenté además a dos
selecciones que tienen objetivos
completamente distintos para este año un
partido muy interesante un embley desde
el punto de vista de mercadeo creo que
es un golazo tanto de la uefa como de la
conmebol de haber encontrado en estos
dos equipos porque cuando italia gana la
eurocopa evidentemente llamó mucho la
atención su estilo de juego la manera de
imponerse durante todo el torneo y
también está argentina no una argentina
que desde 2002 creo que no ilusiona va
tanto ese equipo de bielsa ahora esta
construcción a partir de la copa américa
del eje de messi y una selección mucho
más joven creo que promete mucho para lo
que viene para qatar es muy interesante
porque además en medio de esta discusión
sobre en qué punto está el fútbol
sudamericano versus el fútbol europeo es
el momento digamos indicado para que se
midan fuerzas y nunca estos partidos van
a ser del todo amistosos porque para
mancini después de esta crisis que
supone no clasificar al mundial
evidentemente se va a poner en juego o
muy en digamos en evaluación su idea y
lo que quiere construir con esta italia
que recupera a sus figuras espinas o la
que nos hizo falta en todas la serie de
eliminatoria y evidentemente un montón
de figuras empezando por donde en el
arco que van a hacer digamos que esa
columna vertebral del equipo de mancini
y luego para escalón y ya es la puesta a
punto para el mundial de qatar que
evidentemente por lo mostrado en las
eliminatorias sudamericanas es un equipo
que tiene competir que tiene como
competir y evidentemente son los
europeos los rivales a vencer en este
mundial de qatar